ahora que hemos entendido el concepto de
actividad óptica vamos a hacer algunas
algunos cálculos distintos así que si
tenemos por ejemplo como en este
problema cuando tenemos 0.3 gramos de
colesterol natural y es disuelto en 15
mililitros de cloroformo y colocado en
un tubo polar y metro de 10 centímetros
la rotación observada a 20 grados
celsius es de menos 0.63 calcula la
rotación específica del colesterol y
como vimos en el último vídeo la
rotación específica está relacionada con
la rotación observada y también vimos
que tenía que ver con la concentración y
la longitud de la trayectoria verdad o
la longitud de nuestro tubo y dijimos
que la concentración debería estar dado
en gramos por mililitro si la longitud
debería estar en decímetros verdad y de
hecho la fórmula que teníamos era la
siguiente que la rotación específica era
igual a la rotación observada dividida
entre la concentración
la longitud verdad y como mencionamos
hace unos momentos y dijimos en el vídeo
anterior la concentración debe estar en
gramos por mililitro mientras que la
longitud debe estar en decímetros verdad
todo esto para estandarizar los
resultados y entonces podremos
simplemente sustituir los datos que nos
dan en este problema verdad primero nos
dicen que por ejemplo la rotación
observada desde menos 0.63 entonces aquí
tenemos menos 0.63 dividido entre la
concentración ahora cuál es la
concentración es el número de gramos
entre el número de mili litros aquí
tenemos 0.3 gramos verdad de colesterol
de hecho voy a quitar el los gramos sólo
para no hacer complicado esto tenemos
0.3 disuelto en 15 mililitros de hecho
dije que iba a quitar las unidades
verdad dividido entre 15 mililitros y
que multiplica a la longitud verdad la
longitud es de 10 centímetros
pero tenemos que convertir eso a
decímetros y eso es un decímetro verdad
ahí lo tenemos entonces esta rotación
específica nos da
bueno podemos sacar la calculadora
tenemos menos 0.63 dividido entre 0.3 y
como estamos dividiendo entre 15 se
puede pasar multiplicando verdad
entonces simplemente hay que multiplicar
por 15 y nos da menos 30 y 1.5 entonces
el resultado es menos 30 y 1.5 es la
rotación específica del colesterol
natural eso nos dice que el colesterol
hará que la luz rote hacia la izquierda
verdad y esa es su rotación específica
así que ahora vamos a seguir adelante y
vamos a especificar la temperatura
verdad porque esto depende de la
temperatura y de la longitud de onda
entonces si nos dice que estamos a 20
creo que debería haber puesto el 20 en
otro lado si estamos a 20 grados
centígrados ahora si verdad y estamos
usando por ejemplo la lámpara de sodio
verdad entonces la rotación específica
es menos 30 y 1.5
así que eso fue un cálculo muy sencillo
vamos a ver otro tipo de cálculos para
la actividad óptica y este cálculo nos
permite descubrir lo que conocemos como
la pureza óptica de tu muestra o que a
veces también se le conoce como el
exceso en anti homérico así que vamos a
fijarnos en la pureza óptica y a veces
como ya mencionamos se puede llamar
exceso en anti américo ok vamos a vamos
a denunciar esto esto es la pureza
óptica
óptica o también es el exceso en anti
américo
antia médico y este es un porcentaje muy
fácil de calcular el porcentaje del
exceso en anti américo se puede calcular
simplemente como
la rotación específica observada que
tenemos de nuestra muerte de nuestra
muestra ok digamos es la rotación
específica observada dividido entre la
rotación específica del enantiómero puro
ok del que a lo mejor estamos buscando
pero puro muy bien entonces y si
queremos que esto nos dé un porcentaje
pues multiplicamos por 100 verdad y esto
ahora sí es un porcentaje y podemos usar
estos cálculos para abordar el siguiente
problema nos dice un químico produce ere
carbono pero sospecha que el producto
está contaminado con ese carbón a la
rotación específica del producto es
menos 50 calcula el porcentaje del
exceso en anti homérico del producto así
que si queremos encontrar el porcentaje
del exceso en anti homérico de este
producto necesitamos saber la rotación
específica del delantero puro verdad y
nuestro objetivo es llegar al ere
carbono y el de carbono ya dijimos que
huele como hierbabuena así que
necesitamos saber la rotación específica
de la r carbono verdad y hablamos de eso
en el último vídeo de hecho dijimos que
la rotación específica de esta molécula
a 20 grados es menos 61 aunque entonces
la rotación específica la rotación
específica de esta de la r carbón a 20
grados celsius con usando la lámpara de
sodio es de menos 61 entonces podemos
usar esta fórmula del porcentaje en anti
américo verdad perdón del porcentaje del
exceso en anti américo
y esto simplemente sería la rotación
específica observada que en este caso
nos dice que es de menos 50 verdad
dividido entre la de la rotación
específica del enantiómero puro que en
este caso es de menos 61 verdad y
finalmente multiplicamos por 100 y ese
resultado cuánto nos daban pensemos
tenemos menos 50 dividido entre menos 61
nos da
creo que creo que hubo algún error haber
demos menos 50 dividido entre menos 61 y
ahora si nos da 0.81 96 y si
multiplicamos por 100 eso nos da 81.9
que es más o menos 82 verdad más o menos
un 82 por ciento de exceso del
enantiómero r verdad del carbón a ahora
si nos ponemos a pensar un poquito y
quisiéramos calcular el porcentaje real
de la de la r carbono y de la s carbono
que tenemos en nuestra mezcla final
bueno pues entonces sólo tendríamos que
pensar en dos números cuya suma nos da
100 pero cuya resta nos da 82 verdad eso
nos diría cierto porcentaje de r más
cierto porcentaje de s nos da al 100 y
la diferencia nos da este 82 entonces
por ejemplo si tenemos 91 por ciento de
algo y 9 por ciento de algo la suma nos
da 100 y justamente la red
nos da 91 91 9 son 82 verdad entonces
eso nos está diciendo que tenemos un 91
por ciento de nuestra molécula de carbón
a verdad por ejemplo qué hubiera pasado
si hubiéramos tenido que la rotación
específica observada desde menos 61
entonces el porcentaje del exceso este
en anti américo perdón sería menos 61
dividido entre menos 61 si seguimos esta
fórmula de arriba multiplicada por 100 y
estas son unas cuentas muy fáciles
porque esto nos da justamente el 100 por
ciento verdad 100 por ciento eso quiere
decir que tendríamos un 100 por ciento
de r carbono y 0 por ciento de ese
carbono